These are dangerous times godzilla's out there
and he's hurting people and we don't know why
we need kong the world needs him stop
what's coming through the entrance in
antarctica we could help him find a new
home
the myths are real there was a war
and they're the last ones standing
who bows for who kong bows to no
one
oh my god this is so massive
evacuation titan alert. Now this is alert a drill
I think one of the most exciting things about
doing a godzilla movie is being able to take
a different approach to godzilla in the same
way that the original films did the legendary
approach has always been sort of that godzilla's
a good guy you know he's misunderstood but he's
a good guy and we're kind of flipping the
world around and saying now a world where
godzilla has seemingly turned his back on humanity
and is acting recklessly the massive titan once
thought to be a hero to humanity made landfall
in pensacola florida this film starts after three
years since the last encounter with the titans and
godzilla is on the rampage again why we don't know
there's a recurring motif in this movie of
godzilla sort of being equatable to jaws so even
at the beginning of the film you know we wanted
to treat it more like jaws approaching the shores
my absolute favorite thing that i was always
looking forward to in the movies was godzilla
using his breath i just thought that was the
coolest thing every time you got to see it
and so i ended up pushing that a lot in this movie
I believe godzilla's most recent attacks
haven't just been random i'm at the same opinion
brian tyree henry plays a really fun character
in the film named bernie hayes who's a bit of
a conspiracy theorist for five years
i embedded myself inside this company
trying to figure out what their game was and
then boom godzilla shows up he's a champion
for mankind you know there's something his
heart is so big bernie is kind of this crazy
that's about it he's just crazy all right matt how
to join the wrapping hole the trio of madison josh
and bernie they're all very distinct personalities
but there's a dynamic between them and a rapport
that's been great to watch they're an amazing team
they work really well together they complement
each other so well you know you have the realist
which is josh i mean he's very practical logical
you need one of those in your group otherwise
you're going to die are you sure we can trust this
guy yeah why well mainly because he says crazy all the time and carries a bottle of whiskey
from his dead wife like a gun and then you have
the full go-getter i am the go-getter i will
throw myself into you know if they're scared
to go in first i'll go i think it's romantic
and bernie is the knowledge of the
group you know he really holds a
lot of information he's a conspiracy
theorist so he is extremely intelligent
all three of those actors are just hilarious
and they just they have such great chemistry
together and they're just unbelievably
funny like when the camera is rolling
when it's not rolling it's kind of never
ending with those guys we're going in yeah
this is like the heavyweight
champion of the world fight
there's basically two giant monsters fighting khan
has the strength but you know godzilla can like
you know fire stuff out of it this is the most
epic battle of all time
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new godzilla versus kong trailervideo we finally have some brand new mechagodzilla
footage we'll break down so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a whole bunch of stuff coming
up next week the movie is going to be released
pretty much everywhere by next wednesday but as
you see we finally get some big mechagodzilla
scenes in the new trailers this is a scene of them
activating mechagodzilla in his underground base
and him arising through that massive hatch the
way they present the scene in the trailer doesn't
really give you an idea for the actual scale of
it but you have to imagine that mechagodzilla
is about the same size as real godzilla so it's
massive if you haven't seen any classic toho
monster films this is meant to be a big callback
reference to the classic mechagodzilla movie
is a similar setup to what their base was like
the scientists had built him in an underground
mountain lair and when they unleashed him when
they activated him he rose up to this giant hatch
in the ground to fight godzilla you also get a
really good look at his new design too in the
new monster verse movies he's got these dorsal
spikes that seem similar to godzilla's they also
probably light up like godzilla's when he's using
his abilities in the red light in his eye sockets
lighting up when they activate him like he's
some kind of giant transformer then you see
him plant one of his massive metal feet on the
ground like he's taking a step the director of
the movie even came out and said finally revealed
and actually posted this on his official instagram
account like yes of course mechagodzilla is in
the movie i guess the secret is out quote unquote
just everybody telling the big joke because we've
known about mechagodzilla for weeks and weeks now
in the way they explain the timeline of the
movie in these other clips they say it's been
three years since the event of godzilla king of
monsters when godzilla defeated king ghidorah and
took back the title king of all titans there's way
more footage of that fake hollow earth facility
that they take kong to in them discussing the
plan to take him there why they're taking him
there like they talk about taking him through the
arctic to try and help him out take him to a new
home for some reason i'm assuming based on the
rest of the movie and the footage we've seen in
the trailers it's because of the threat that they
think godzilla poses when teen kong whether or not
they're actually associated with monarch or not
thinks that godzilla has completely turned on man
and the director also kind of clarifies that
during this clip too where he says he wanted
to flip the script and play at least part of the
movie as if godzilla was no longer a friend to man
of course it's a total fake out i'll explain in
a second but it's just that every single godzilla
movie that he says so far in the monster verse
films the new monster verse films godzilla has
always been portrayed as an ally so they wanted
to start off things in this new film in total
godzilla jaws mode and i'm assuming everyone has
seen at least one of the jaws films or you're at
least familiar with the concept but i do love the
deep cut reference and it tracks because godzilla
is just at home in deep water as he is on land
he's not strictly a land-based titan like some
of them although most of them could probably swim
a little to save their lives if they had to like
kong is capable of swimming it's just that some
of them are way less suited to exist underwater
like kong of course which i think is probably one
of the reasons why they wanted that first godzilla
versus kong throwdown fight to happen on the ships
in deep water because it does seem like godzilla
scores the first major win there like i said
it all seems like a big misdirect like you pit
ali versus foreman in a battle of the titans when
really there's all this mechagodzilla stuff going
on in the background there is a brand new scene
of this apex scientist watching godzilla attacking
the city in the distance because as you see in the
other footage when the director is hyping up his
atomic breath ability he keeps blasting straight
into the ground as if he's trying to destroy
something underneath the ground and there's all
that other footage at the beginning of that clip
of the apex base itself like you see the apex
logo here with all the warning alarms going
off saying that there's a titan attack coming so
clearly godzilla is just looking for the secret
underground volcano lair of mechagodzilla trying
to destroy it although it's not clear how godzilla
finds out about mechagodzilla it probably
has something to do with the apex scientists
testing out mechagodzilla's systems and that's
what alerts godzilla but then they explain more
of how brian tyree henry's character is connected
to apex confirming my theory from a while ago
he says his character bernie hayes started out as
a conspiracy theorist who just infiltrated apex
to learn what they were doing and discovered the
truth about them experimenting with titan dna and
mechagodzilla and all these really shady plans
that they have to get rid of the real titans
he also clarified that he'd been inside the
company for five years when the movie picks up
meaning that he was inside of apex before the
events of godzilla king of monsters it sounds
like apex's plans have been in motion for many
many years prior to the events of even the first
new godzilla monsterverse movie monarch had been
investigating titans long before the events of
kong skull island 2 and that movie took place
in the 1970s so i think they'll also get more
into the ancient history of the titans during the
movie and it sounds like they'll also explain how
apex got its start too but if you haven't seen
they've actually been posting a lot of early
reviews for the movie generally it's what you want
to hear pretty favorable everyone does seem like
they're hyping it up but most of the criticisms
are actually against the human storyline saying
it kind of bogs the film down a little which is
common i think for godzilla big titan movies like
everyone wants to see less of the human storylines
and more of godzilla and the other titans but i
think the idea with the last two godzilla movies
is that because it's gotten cheaper to do the
visual effects for the titans they've been able to
slowly pull back on the amount of human storyline
and make more and more of the story just about
the titans so hopefully that trend continues in
potential future godzilla movies or monsterverse
movies but just big reminder that the movie is
coming out on hbo max next week and in theaters
on the same day but it is out early in a couple
countries today so be careful for spoilers
on twitter facebook social media in general
but if you spotted any big easter eggs during
this new footage that i didn't talk about during
the video just write it below in the comments and
like i said all my videos for the movie will start
posting next week i've got some new justice league
snyder cut videos that i'll post in my full marvel
falcon and winter soldier episode 2 video we'll
post friday just like normal will you wait for
everything click here for my full justice league
snyder cut ending and end credit scenes video
and click here for my brand new falcon
and winter soldier episode 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!